as tradições africanas são tradições e
são civilizações da palavra falada
isto é uma tradição oral em áfrica o
testemunho é passado de geração em
geração através da palavra falada até na
áfrica ocidental que a partir do século
já existia a escrita ela ficava para
trás porque o prouni dá pra dominava
sempre a palavra falada em moçambique
não é diferente
moçambique é uma tradição da palavra
falada nós em moçambique
começamos todas as nossas histórias com
carga no local enganar o povo fonte para
enganar
para além desta tradição falada existem
áfrica outra seleção que é dos símbolos
africanos
esta é outra forma como os povos
africanos comunicam uns com os outros e
moçambique esta tradição não é tão forte
como no ocidente africano cujo símbolo
de africanos são 20 em quase tudo e no
dia a dia dos povos africanos
e são estes mesmos símbolos que mais
tarde passam para além dos utensílios
diários para aquilo que nós já usamos
como tecido africano a capulana acapo
lana é o tecido que todos nós usamos
capulana faz parte da nossa tradição
agora o plano encontramos em todo o
sítio as mulheres que fazem mecão de
bege nós amarramos capulana para tudo e
é uma vergonha como por uma mulher
africana não ter uma cúpula na carteira
né
as nossas mães nossas tias de ensino
anos que isso faz parte da nossa
tradição eo promotor
alguém sabe de onde vem esta capulana
como é que ela chegou sabe como ela
chegou à áfrica quem fez a primeira
capulana como ela foi concebida o que
significavam os desenhos e os símbolos
que estavam nela alguém sabe responder
a primeira capulana chega à áfrica no
século 19 das enxurradas primeiro em
campanha em mombaça e na ilha de
moçambique
esse foi o primeiro foram os primeiros
pontos que este se do tempo
o contato com o povo africano no século
ela chega ocidente africano pela mão de
joão desde que era uma imitação do
tecido java da indonésia e islã desde
quando chegaram indonésia gostaram do
java e decidiram criar uma tecnologia
pra imitar é este esta produção e foram
industrializar a produção e eles
voltaram ainda neve a na esperança de
que iam começar um negócio novo e qual
foi o espanto deus quando eu sinto foi
rejeitado o que os disseram nós
preferimos jeito nosso tecido
tradicional feito à mão e hoje tinham
criado um produto que já não tenha
mercado e quando estava voltar pro
holanda foram a gol costa que o gana e
lá a que o povo gostou deste sítio e foi
a partir daí capulana sido africano que
tenha anda ancara no gana chegou à
áfrica
hoje o mercado africano é qualificado a
5 bilhões de dólares diz 5 bilhões de
dólares somente quem por cento fica em
áfrica
isto é nós fazemos parto ou nós
consumimos um produto do qual nós não
temos nenhum benefício econômico o
benefício econômico deste produto vai
todo para a china
aprendi a prolongada a maior empresa de
produção de têxteis africana em uma
empresa holandesa é eu domino o mercado
africano com 30% de todas as vendas
então eu pergunto pergunta vocês disse o
tecido africano desta indústria têxtil
africana qual é a parte que é africana
além do consumidor
qual é o papel que nós temos neste todo
o processo de produção faz sentido pra
vocês é o maior símbolo da nossa
identidade que é capulana seja produzido
por outros
faz sentido que nós deixamos com mais
uma vez na nossa história seja contada
por outros
eles não entendem o que o nosso dia a
dia eu
não sabem o que é a nossa cultura eles
não sabem o que queremos um bico que é a
áfrica do sul morreu domingo à nossa
história e os criam esses tecidos e os
trazem nós consumimos e nunca nos
perguntamos qual deveria ser a nossa
real parte nunca paramos para pensar em
ganhar do víamos fazer parte dessa
indústria de uma forma muito mais
robusta que devíamos tentar produzir
nosso próprio tecido todas as fábricas
que existiram que existiram do do plano
até hoje
hoje em dia já fecharam porque não
aguentaram com a indústria que veio da
china e isso não há nada que trava estas
planos de entrar nos nossos países não
há nada que protege a nossa indústria
nacional
dentro desta tendência
e eu digo nós decidimos em 2015
queríamos fazer parte deste movimento em
eu estava a fazer o mestrado do do
tecido na alemanha e quando eu estava
crescendo verdade é que o banhista
capulana eu fui à holanda para
investigar mais sobre esta plana e
quando eu cheguei a holanda eu fui à
fábrica e eu entrevistei los como é que
vocês fazem a kaplan
como é que vocês interpretam as culturas
africanas como é que vocês ponham os
símbolos africanos qual é parta que os
criadores africanos e os pensadores
africano dos nossos contos a nossa
cultura como é que ela é integrada neste
sítio que vocês criam e os não saberão
responder
eles não souberam dizer qual era a nossa
parte e os morros ponderam nós não
entramos com os africanos no instrumento
desenhamos um tecido que os consomem
nós criamos tudo aqui à porta fechada e
vamos deixar em áfrica e os compram mas
por que vocês não entrarem com os
africanos porque sempre que nós tentamos
fazer alguma coisa com ele eu saí uma
coisa assim meio e medíocre
meio do mercadinho e eu fiquei chocada e
eu percebi nenhum momento que ela nem se
apercebeu que eu era africana e caminha
forma de falar por ter um uma pronúncia
muito americana veja esquecer que quem
estava em frente dela era uma olhar
negra e movimenta-se não era africana
descendência africana e os outros
colegas ficaram meio envergonhados e eu
decidi que o dia muito indignada com o
que eu vi que não ia fazer parte dos
consumidores que eu não ia mais deixaram
com os outros ditassem aqui o meu povo
devia consumir e que eu ia criar a minha
própria empresa de tecidos e que eu
podia dizer a minha capulana porque nada
melhor do que ninguém
nada melhor do que eu para perceber e
saber quem são as mulheres africanas can
é o povo africano do que os gostam quais
são as histórias por respeitarem as
contas e quando eu cheguei a moçambique
e conhecia de milan
assim nasceu a enganou carini gana
escolhemos de ensino mesmo de propósito
porque nós contar a história a gente
sido nós queremos mudar a narrativa da
indústria têxtil africana através das
histórias que nós contamos através da
minha história da sua história e da
história dos nossos povos nós queremos
que a história de moçambique ea áfrica
sai um de nós presos e não que sejam
hoje editarmos como é que devia ser
porque estamos um período que todos nós
queremos procurar soluções e buscar as
soluções dentro pra fora
ninguém pode criar uma solução para nós
sem perceber as dificuldades que são
trabalhar em moçambique
ninguém conhece o nosso povo melhor do
que nós e não entramos nisso com uma uma
cabeça de sonhadora
percebemos que é uma caminhada muito
longa e que há muitas outras coisas que
têm de acontecer precisa ser verdade já
existir uma indústria têxtil precisamos
de escolas de moda exames de técnicos de
moda precisamos de engenheiros testem os
precisamos de ter a cadeia toda de
valores do tecido e moçambicana desde o
algodão o fio a linha até o tecido
hoje isso precisa acontecer de uma
maneira muito bem pensada e já existe
esta forma de pensar
mas nós todos temos que perceber que é
preciso levar esta coisa séria
não podemos pensar o que é moda ou acapo
ana é uma coisa só de cultura é um
negócio e um negócio que dá muito
dinheiro se é bem feito e é uma
indústria que pode mudar a cara do nosso
país é uma indústria que tem o valor tem
um valor cultural mas também tem o valor
monetário
e é assim que nós devíamos olhar para
esta tal de topo lana que nós todos
usamos eu partilho da história com vocês
não só para falar sobre a minha empresa
ou aquilo que nós queremos fazer porque
nós achamos que nós somos as únicas que
pensamos assim
mas podemos dizer que quando se tem um
sonho e quantos descida quando nós vamos
deixar de ser consumidores é possível é
possível fazer e nós devíamos fazer não
estão os jovens e há uma geração toda
que procura uma nova identidade africana
uma identidade que é construída por nós
e não é dita que aquilo que vem de fora
é melhor que o nosso
nós não queremos rejeitará a cultura dos
nossos avós de ensino
todo mundo para voltar para trás e já
decidiu aquilo que é importante é que o
que vem da raiz
então tá na hora do nosso tamanho
aprendemos a contar as nossas próprias
histórias